[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the director
of the demos think tank polly mckenzie
and the pr consultant alex dean they'll
be with us from now until just before
midnight
so let's see what's on some of the front
pages for you now
leading with the power plant attack in
ukraine the financial times has the
headline russia in reckless nuclear site
strike
the telegraph quotes boris johnson
insisting that the world had narrowly
avoided a nuclear catastrophe as a
result
the guardian has that line as well
the express also mentions the prime
minister reassuring ukrainians that
british weapons are on the way to help
the mirror pictures vladimir putin and
describes him as wanted for war crimes
the times pictures a distressed woman
outside a burning building in a suburb
of kiev
that same image is on the front of the
eye which says putin is stepping up the
onslaught
the mail highlights a new three-year
visa scheme allowing ukrainian refugees
to come to the uk
while the star leads with the passing of
the former australian cricket captain
shane warne calling him the greatest
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and alex dean welcome to you
both um let's start with the
i uh weekend uh and their story uh
suggesting that the the onslaught
actually has been stepped out but the
violence has escalated in informed polly
well as we understand it putin expected
that this would be a quick and easy war
and as that hasn't played out it seems
every day there is a new escalation of
violence
we're going to go through the papers and
it in a way it's hard to disentangle
what's worse is it the the vindictive
cruelty
of these explosions like the one that's
pictured here is it the recklessness um
will come onto the nuclear attack at the
nuclear power station that was attacked
or is it just the the
mindless futility of it all um it's it's
incredibly difficult to you know to read
these papers without being upset without
being angry uh and and to have just
immense i think horror and pity and
distress about the you know the lives of
ukrainians which have been
pointlessly
ruined and disrupted in the way that you
know this demonstrates
yes and uh alex we move on to the the
times and the headline there welcome to
hell and this is the the message that um
ukrainians have across a bridge for the
the russian soldiers who are entering
their their village and they're willing
to fight to the death
and it is extraordinary the show of
bravery and commitment being put on by
ukrainians of all ages and backgrounds
to rise up and defend their country
against
the russians and of course as we've also
been hearing it's not quite covered in
the same wheel of france today we've
been hearing in recent days about many
russian conscripts sent unwillingly to
war often told they were going for a
training exercise
and then finding themselves in live
combat against people they have no issue
with themselves and deserting in quite
significant numbers but we run the risk
of being more optimistic than we should
be and tomorrow's fronts are a real
corrective for that
we've seen kharkiv ukraine's second city
to major city international airport one
and a half million people with areas
around it that look like the worst kind
of of movie where you know
apocalyptic scenes but there's a great
city of large chunks that have been laid
wasted and tonight the city of mariopol
half a million souls is without food
water or electricity this is building up
into an appalling situation it's all
plainly vladimir putin's fault but the
problem is his behavior is getting worse
not better and polly we must talk about
the the nuclear catastrophe narrowly
avoided the telegraph covering that on
its front page and boys johnson warning
that radioactive cloud threatens europe
and u.s declares nato is ready for
conflict after russian power plant
assault this really has ratcheted up
another level hasn't it
it has i mean i think it's important to
try and calibrate our understanding of
the scale of risk that was faced during
this
um because this people have been talking
about chernobyl um the the nuclear
reactor that exploded and this is you
know a much safer much more resilient
building so in terms of people being
immediately terrified i think we don't
need to but nevertheless the idea that
you would fire missiles at a nuclear
power plant because even though it's
probably gonna be okay and the reactors
will carry on being cooled by the water
supply that
the insanity of that risk that you are
going to run to then not allow emergency
services into
to put those fires out i think it
demonstrates that there is something
just
barbaric
uh um and mindless about the approach
that the russians are taking
you know this is not
judicious warfare with thoughtful
targets to try and take out uh
individual military sites um they are
not targeting ukrainian military they
are targeting civilians they are
targeting hospitals they're targeting
residential areas and and this just
capsule we have to presume
the intention was to take out the power
supply to worsen the humanitarian crisis
and um and damage the morale of
ukrainian citizens but as alex has said
that morale remains astonishingly high
as they continue their incredibly brave
flight
polly and alex thank you for the moment
we are going to take a break coming up
we'll look back at the life and career
of the former australian cricket captain
shane ward to stay with us
[Music]
welcome back just want to bring you some
breaking news um coming in from devon
and cornwall police they say an elderly
woman in her 80s has died and a second
person has been injured after an hm
coast guard helicopter
landed at the helipad at derriford
hospital an initial investigation is
being conducted by devon and cornwall
police assisted by a number of partner
agencies so just to reiterate that news
just
police say an elderly woman in her 80s
has died and a second person has been
injured after an hm coast guard
helicopter landed at the helipad at
derriford hospital we're bringing more
on that story as soon as we have it
well with me now to take us through the
rest of the papers polly mckenzie and
alex dean uh welcome back to you both um
let's start with the star and um the
subpassing the australian creator shane
warn at the age of just 52 they have
been pictured on the front page alex
yeah i don't know how many times i've
watched the footage of the ball of the
century uh where he um
took mike getting there you go i mean i
probably i've watched it probably almost
as many times as mike gatlings had
nightmares about it was absolutely
fascinating bit of wizardry and i i'd
forgotten until your coverage reminded
us of it that it was his very first ball
in the atlas an extraordinary man and he
lived life totally to the full i loved
listening to matthew hayden um he wasn't
he wasn't being inappropriate before um
warren died matty hayden former
australian opener told a story about the
first time he ever saw shane warne and
looked like he was just bursting with
human life he was um you'll forgive me
smoking in one hand and a pie in the
other he was clearly getting over a
massive hangover and he was uh competing
in a state champ state state match
against queensland against victoria i
mean the man could um do things that
people other people in qriket simply
didn't understand we've lost him far too
and of course he also dated little early
i know i mean the man was a remarkable
force of nature and i fear we will not
see his like again yes a huge character
apolly and distinctive with that that
shock of peroxide uh hair not really
what you might have thought a cricketer
should look like
uh yeah he had as much charisma as he
had talent you know you know that that
clip is a remarkable one but you could
spend hours i think watching amazing
amazing feats of wizardry i think is a a
great word but also he was a brilliant
commentator um and a qriket because it
lasts so long it's brought to life by
its commentators who add the analysis
and the
the
i don't know the random sort of
uh distractions and and the and the
witterings and that go on during the tea
break and the change of ends and all of
that so
he he just brought life and his love of
cricket i think to share with everybody
who um who got the chance to to watch or
hear him speak
alex you were nodding and smiling there
i suspect you enjoyed his role as a
commentator
i i really did i was thinking reflecting
as polly was talking i think probably
um after
um richie bennett and teddy greg you're
probably my favorite commentator to
listen to because he knew the game
backwards but he also wasn't shy of
telling you a little bit about the
personalities and a bit of the behind
the scenes uh activity in
in amongst these great sportsmen that
you look up to i thought he was a
brilliant person to watch talking about
the game he excelled at as well as
somebody um who was brilliant to watch
playing it also i i like to listen to
qriket commentary on the radio um
sometimes and if you
he had a a surprise really distinctive
voice and i mean distinctive in every
sense distinctive in the way he sounded
and distinctive in the plain spoken but
acute observations that he uh would
offer and i i thought he was
he was a great character in the game 52
is no age at all is it